you know well you worked with lee lee
has this idea of evolutionary black
holes and that in the genesis of each
black hole is another universe with
differently tuned constants and it's
predictive in the sense that
if we're in the typical member of the
space of universes we should see certain
formations of black holes be maximal
because the universe is constantly
trying to maximize the amount of black
holes it creates now
is that similar to this was this spawned
by it
is it a question can this can that be
derived from this is it distinct yeah
i mean so lee
um to my memory you know
was the person that came up with the
landscape um
idea in that in that in that instance in
that um picture of black holes spawning
and being used as
a mechanism
to determine not to determine but to
populate this landscape um with
different parameters of our standard
model for example so
of the coupling constants so it's um
so
that i would say this is um in that
spirit for sure because obviously
for many years i've been talking with
lee about how do we get around the
issues of how theories might determine
the the values of the standard model
and what mechanisms
um exist so one of the things i paid a
lot of attention to when i worked in
string phenomenology
right which is how string theory can
give us back the real world
um
was basically yeah i mean how you know
this was a big question um
and
one way out of course is that
if string theory gave you something like
um
um like
like eternal inflation then the idea
there was that the the different parts
of the universe that are inflated would
populate
the stamp you know the different
parameters and we happen to be living in
one of them so that's one you hit the
jackpot type of idea
um
the other one
so but you know i've always kept an open
mind about other alter other ways of
thinking about maybe there's something
about the theory itself that's
determined in this and so the idea here
is to really simply put a learn to think
that maybe there's some kind of learning
in this in the sense of artificial
neural network
um but instead of it being a neural
network is the degrees of freedom
instead of being a neural network it's
actually the matrices which are now the
fundamental degrees of freedom that are
playing the role of the perception with
perceptrons and then the weights are
being adjusted the hope is that it's
going to be the parameters of the
standard model that's it that's it
interesting
but
one out one out i would say to get to
give myself an out here is that a quote
from albert einstein you know if we knew
what we were talking about we wouldn't
call it research so so there's a part of
me that i'm we're still confused about a
couple of things which is why it's great
talking to smart people like yourself so